bonjour à toutes et à tous mes chers
collègues nous commençons nos travaux de
ce matin par l'examen de la proposition
de résolution tendant à la création
d'une commission d'enquête sur
l'attribution le contenu et le contrôle
des autorisations de servicees de
télévision à caractère national sur la
télé télévision numérique terrestre ou
dit TNT le pour l'examen c'est la
proposition numéro
1743 la présidente du groupe la France
insoumise nupes a fait savoir à
l'occasion de la réunion de la
Conférence des présidents du 17 octobre
dernier que son groupe souhaitait
utiliser son droit de tirage pour la
création de cette commission en
application du second alinéa de
l'article 140 de notre règlement il
appartient à notre commission à laquelle
la proposition de résolution a été
renvoyé de vérifier sa recevabilité sans
se sans se prononcer sur son opportunité
ni pouvoir amender son dispositif et
j'insiste sur le fait que on ne peut on
ne se prononce pas sur sur son
opportunité ce matin mais juste de
savoir si effectivement on on a bien les
toutes tous les caractère de de
recevabilité pour dire oui ou non donc
et nous avons désigné monsieur Quentin
bataillon rapporteur sur cette
proposition je vais donc lui donner la
parole et après la brève intervention de
Monsieur bataillon si les orateurs des
groupes puis d'autres memes de la
commission souhaaitent s'exprimer je
leur donnerai la parole et chacun aura
une minute monsieur bataillon c'est à
vous merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues lors de la conférence des
présidents du 17 octobre 2023 la
présidente du groupe la France insumupes
a indiqué faire usage pour la création
de la commission d'enquête prévue par
cette proposition de résolution dont je
salue la présence de l'auteur ici avec
nous ce matin du droit de tirage que le
2ème alinéa de l'article 141 du
Règlement de l'Assemblée nationale
reconnaît à chaque président de groupe
d'opposition ou de groupes minoritaires
une fois par session ordinaire en
conséquence conformément en second
alinéa de l'article 140 du règlement il
revient à notre commission de vérifier
que les conditions requises pour la
création de la commission d'enquête sont
réunies je souhaite préciser que nous
devons nous prononcer aujourd'hui sur la
recevabilité et non sur l'opportunité de
la création de cette commission
d'enquête je dis ceci à la fois pour le
rapport mais aussi pour les questions
qui pourraient suivre trois conditions
sont requises en premier lieu en
application de l'article 137 de notre
règlement les proposition de résolution
entendant la création de commissions
d'enquête doivent déterminer avec
précision les faits qui donnent lieu à
enquête en l'occurrence les faits sembl
définis avec une précision suffisante
puisque selon l'article unique de la
proposition de résolution la commission
d'enquête serait chargée de je cite
faire toute la lumière sur les
procédures d'attribution des
autorisations de servicees de télévision
à caractère national sur la Télévision
Numérique Terrestre TNT sur le respect
des engagements pris par ces services de
télévision et enfin sur les moyens de
contrôle du respect de ses engagements
mis en œuvre par l'Autorité de
régulation de la communication
audiovisuelle et numérique harcom
l'exposé des motifs précise par ailleurs
que les travaux de la commission
porteraient plus spécifiquement sur la
procédure d'attribution de fréquence
pour la diffusion de chaînes de la TNT
par l'arcom le respect des engagements
pris par les chaînes bénéficiaires de
ces autorisations d'usage de la
ressources
radioélectrique notamment pour celles
dont les contrats arrivent à échéance
les moyens mis à disposition par l'Arcam
pouront s'assurer du respect de ses
engagements le premier critère est donc
rempli en second lieu de T proposition
de résolution sont recevables sauf si
dans l'année qui précède leur discussion
a eu lieu une commission d'enquête ayant
le même objet ce n'est pas le cas en
l'espèce bien que les travaux de notre
commission a pu à plusieurs occasions
aborder certaines thématiques évoquées
par la proposition de résolution le
deuxème critère de recevabilité est donc
également satisfait enfin en application
d'article 139 du règlement la
proposition de résolution ne peut être
mise en discussion si le garde des sauts
fait connaître des poursuites
judiciaires en cours sur les faits ayant
motivé le dépôt d' opposition le 3è
alinéa de l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du
17 novembre 1958 prévoit même que la
mission d'une commission d'enquête déjà
créé prend fin dès l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire relative aux
faits sur lesquels elle est chargé
d'enquêter interrogé par la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale le garde des
saut lui a fait savoir par un courrier
du 7 novembre 2023 hier que le périmètre
de la commission d'enquête envisagé est
susceptible de recouvrir pour partie
celui d'une information judiciaire en
cours ouverte du chef de trafic
d'influence et suivi par par le parquet
national financier il précise en at que
ce périmètre est également susceptible
de recouvrir plusieurs procédures en
cours notamment relative au délit de
discrimination ainsi qu'au délit prévu
par la loi du 29 juillet 1881 sur la
presse néanmoins l'existence de
contentieux porté devant les
juridictions ne constittu pas en soi un
obstacle d'iment d'une part à la
commission d'enquête n'aura ni à
connaître ni à se prononcer sur les
litiges susceptible d'opposer les
administrations ou services publics et
les justiciables pas plus sur les
demandes de réparation que ces derniers
pourront porter devant les juridictions
d'autre part ainsi que l'établi le
courer du garde des saut il appartient à
l'Assemblée nationale de veiller à
l'articulation de l'enquête
parlementaire avec les procédures
judiciaires la commission d'enquête
devra donc veiller tout au long de ses
travaux à ne pas étendre ses
investigations à des faits faisant objet
d'instance devant l'autorité judiciaire
dès lors et sous réserve l'existence de
procédure en cours n'entraîn pas
l'irrecevabilité de la présente
proposition de résolution au regard de
l'article 139 du règlement de
l'Assemblée nationale il résulte ainsi
de l'analyse qui précède que la
proposition de résolution est
juridiquement
recevable merci monsieur le rapporteur
pour ces rappels donc maintenant je vais
donner la parole au collègues qui
l'avait demander et j'ai comme inscrit
Jean-Jacques Gautier
oui puisqu'il s'agit d'examiner
aujourd'hui des questions de de forme et
non de fond des question de recevabilité
et non de de pertinence d'opportunité
d'ailleurs sur lequel je je m'interroge
à titre personnel et au nom de mon
groupe je n'irai pas plus loin dans les
commentaires aujourd'hui me réservant
pour les travaux de la commission
d'enquête elle-même tout à fait merci
monsieur le député Aurélien
saintoule merci madame la Présidente
chers collègues la télévision française
est-elle à la hauteur des besoins et des
attentes du public certainement pas
racisme sexisme harcèlement violence
vulgarité et abrutissement sont
malheureusement certains des termes qui
caractérise le mieux la production
audiovisuel je suis même sûr que des
noms vous viennent à l'esprit cette
impression flatteuse mérite tout de même
d'être étayé par une enquête sérieuse
les chaînes de télévision qui diffusent
sur la TNT ont obtenu ce droit en
contractant des obligations à l'égard du
public et il est notre devoir de les
faire respecter ma conviction est que le
public qui regarde la télévision a en
fait un droit de regard sur l'usage qui
est fait de ce bien commun que sont les
fréquences attribuées par l'arcom de
fait ces obligations figurent en toute
lettre dans la loi et dans les
conventions signées par les chaînes et
accordées pour une durée déterminé 15
d'entre elles arrivent à échéance en
2025 et donc nous avons la possibilité
de peser dans le processus d'attribution
des fréquences d'assurer la qualité des
programmes et de défendre les exigences
de nos concitoyens une société
démocratique ne peut pas se permettre de
résumer la communication audiovisuelle à
l'objectif de vendre du temps de cerveau
disponible à Coca-Cola et c'est bien
l'objectif de cette commission de le
faire
valoir merci monsieur le député donc je
rappelle que on se prononce sur les
conditions de recevabilité et pas sur le
fond donc je vais donner la parole à
Céline
Calvez merci madame la Présidente la
commission d'enquête visé par la
présente PPR a pour principale ambition
de contrôler la procédure d'attribution
par l'arcom des fréquences de la TNT
nous devons nous assurer que celle-ci
s'effectue dans le respect du droit
positif et que la création d'une telle
commission n'interfère pas de façon
préjudiciable avec les procédures en
cours en effet comme il a été rappelé
l'arcom initiera en 2024 la procédure
d'octroit de 15 fréquences par le biais
d'un appel à candidature les chaînes
existantes devront donc convaincre
l'arcom de renouveler leur autorisation
de diffusion sur le bouquet TV gratuit
face à la concurrence des nouveaux
entrants à ce titre ma question porte
sur le cadrage juridique des objectifs
de cette commission d'enquête cette
dernière se doit en effet d'analyser
avec objectivité et impartialité les
précédentes procédures de distribution
mise en œuvre ainsi que les critères
d'attribution mais ne serait avoir pour
but d'interférer dans la distribution
des chaînes à venir dès lors monsieur le
rapporteur pourriez-vous nous confirmer
que cette commission d'enquête ne pourra
porter que sur les faits antérieurs et
pas sur les événements connexes à sa
mise en œuvre je vous remercie merci
madame la députée Laurent es
queengx merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues saintou je me questionne sur
la pertinence de votre commission
d'enquête l'exposé des motifs indique
que vous interrogez sur les critères
d'attribution de fréquen or la loi de
1986 relative à la liberté de
communication vous y répond h critères
d'attribution dont l'expérience acquise
le pluralisme des courants d'expression
socioculturel il sont spécifiés si le
sujet est important il a déjà été traité
par une commission d'enquête de 2015 qui
avait conduit un renforcement des
procédures d'attribution et de revente
des chaînes TNT il y a moins de 2 ans
une commission d'enquête sénatoriale sur
la concentration des médias rendait
également ses conclusions en réalité
votre commission va créer une suspicion
sur le travail de grande qualité de
l'arcom en bref si le monde des médias
est parcouru par de nombreuses
problématiques les critères
d'attribution des chaînes n'en est pas
un je regrette que vous ne profitiez pas
de votre droit de tirage pour traiter
d'un sujet plus urgent et plus sérieux
je merci monsieur le député je répète
que on ne se prononce pas sur le fond
mais sur la
forme violette pilebou
oui merci madame la
Présidente moi très simplement une
question sur la forme cette commission
d'enquête elle arrive à un moment où on
a les états généraux de l'information où
on a des procédures déjà bien établies
de renouvellement des contrats
d'objectifs et de moyen pour
l'audiovisuel public où il va y avoir
l'année prochaine la réattribution de
canot nt avec des procédures qui comme
l'a rappelé mon collègue Laurent es
queengog sont sont déjà extrêmement bien
définies donc ma question c'est est-ce
que dans cette commission d'enquête nous
allons approfondir le sujet des moyens
qui sont donnés à l'arcom pour pouvoir
exercer son contrôle est-ce que le la
commission d'enquête
va tenir enfin intégrer ce type de sujet
dans l'ensemble de son champ d'action je
vous
remercie merci madame la députée et je
sa enfin il y a des questions auquelles
le rapporteur ne pourra pas répondre
puisque là ce matin on se prononce
vraiment sur la les conditions de
recevabilité et pas sur le fond de la
commission sur le fond du la commission
d'enquête Stéphane Lenormand
oui merci madame la Présidente bon
rapidement puisque vous l'avez bien
évoqué il s'agit d'une d'une question ce
matin plus de de recevalité et de forme
j'aurais eu beaucoup de de questions sur
sur le fond
à ce stade visiblement donc cette
commission d'enquête est rempli les
conditions elle peut sans doute être
intéressante parce que il y a des sujets
mais qui peut-être au vu des travaux de
cette commission finalement vont faire
un cheit mais en tout cas par
transparence nous y serons activement
partiese prenant pour suivre les
travaux merci monsieur le député
monsieur le
rapporteur merci madame la Présidente
merci à l'ensemble des collègues bien
sûr pour leur question et leur intérêt
pour pour cette commission d'enquête si
effectivement je me tiens au seul
critère de recevabilité qui nous réunit
ce matin ce élément qu'effectivement je
je puisse dire c'est qu'effectivement
cette commission d'enquête n'a pas un
rôle de fait prospective puisque c'est
une commission d'enquête qu'elle ne doit
pas effectivement travailler des
procédures judiciaires ce qui n'empêche
pas de travailler sur les procédures des
des
administrations qu'elle aura du coup à
examiner à auditionner en ce sens et
quant à son cadrage juridique
effectivement une commission d'enquête
n'a pas à faire le travail d'une autre
administration notamment sur le sujet
des des renouvellements mais elle pourra
y mettre un avis
seulement merci monsieur le rapporteur
donc donc tout le monde ceux qui avaient
demandé la parole ayant pu s'exprimer
nous allons maintenant procéder au vote
sur la question de recevabilité de la
proposition de résolution qui estime
qu'elle est
recevable
qui est donc qui est pour qui est contre
donc la commission se prononce donc
positivement sur la recevabilité de la
proposition de résolution je vous
remercie